i had a wonderful conversation with
minister reznikov this morning we
discussed operation unifier we discussed
the important aid that canada has put on
the table and
the willingness of our country to
continue to work with
ukraine with our allies and partners
across the nato alliance to support the
stability and security of ukraine now
and going forward minister you're moving
uh canadian forces west of the river
what information do you have that
prompted that change
the safety and security of
the armed forces is my top priority
at all times
and out of an abundance of caution
we are
repositioning some of our troops
why now why not previously the last week
we are continually
monitoring
the
evolving and concerning situation
and made a decision to
move troops
in that regard minister did you hear
anything today in your meeting that
would make you change your mind about
the
present assessment of
the invasions by russia
the meeting this morning was primarily
about the aid that canada put on the
table last wednesday and that we will
continue to execute on for example i
discussed the arrival of the aid i
discussed the expansion of unifier we
discussed how important unifier has been
on the ground to the training of
ukrainian troops including the national
guard
the tenor of the conversation was
very amicable and
resolved to continue the working
relationship going forward so did you
have an opportunity to discuss the
possibility of
restarting a
program of sharing satellite data and
reconnaissance data with the ukrainian
the
issues that we discussed were
broad-ranging
and i in particular asked
for
their assessment of the various types of
aid that would be useful
across the board
we discussed uh cyber security in
particular and how important it is
to make sure that cyber networks are
secure so did you discuss lethal weapons
in the meeting today we discussed
a range of aid across the board and i
committed to bring the information that
was shared with me
by minister rashnikov and his team back
to the canadian government so that we
can continue to ensure that we are
full-fledged in our support for ukraine
that still doesn't answer whether you
specifically brought up the issue of
lethal weapons and i went through your
answer yesterday a couple of times and
i'm still having some trouble
understanding what the threshold is for
candidate to make that commitment so i
realized i've asked you a two-parter
there whether it came up in the meeting
and what the threshold is but if i could
get a direct answer to that i'd
appreciate it well i will give you a
direct answer and the direct answer is
that
we discussed a number of forms of aid
and it would be prudent in light of the
very intense and sensitive security
situation at the current time for me to
discuss that first with my counterparts
in cabinet and with the prime minister
prior to making formal decisions or
announcements about what was discussed
what is your assessments
i will be meeting with the nato
secretary general tomorrow jen
stoltenberg
before heading to latvia and we will
discuss a range of items including how
the nato alliance can continue to be
supportive
of a strong and stable ukraine
merci beaucoup